okay let's talk about estrogen
it's an incredible hormone that we're
only just starting to understand there's
a specific type of estrogens that's made
in the ovaries called estradiol this is
released throughout the menstrual cycle
and it Peaks just around ovulation
research suggests estrogen can have some
powerful effects in 2021 neuroscientists
at the University of California Santa
Barbara for the first time tracked a
woman's hormones throughout the cycle
and looked at whether these had any
impact on the brain they found an
increase in connectivity throughout the
brain at times when estrogen was high
one theory is that estrogen causes our
neurons to form new connections to other
neurons which helps with learning and
memory
relax